As we get closer and closer to the November
election.
I've been talking about how much of Donald
Trump's behavior over the next three months
is going to be coming of a place of desperation,
from a place of desperation, out of a sense
of desperation.
And David Shipler wrote a really interesting
article yesterday in Washington Monthly called
Beware of a Cornered Trump, which really builds
on this idea that you and I have been talking
about for a while, that if Donald Trump's
polling continues to be bad.
And remember, he's pretending like he doesn't
believe the polling, but his actions speak
otherwise, replacing his campaign manager
and all of that, you know, restarting corona
virus briefings, all wearing a mask, all the
things that he's doing.
If his polling doesn't improve, it doesn't
have to necessarily get worse.
But just if it doesn't improve, we would expect,
based on everything we know about Donald Trump,
that he would go even more in the directions
that we have seen him tend to directions of
corruption and depravity and authoritarian
tendencies, which will likely become even
more severe.
And case in point.
We're really already seeing that over the
last couple of weeks, the deployment of camouflaged
troops with no badges to Portland, Oregon,
where they are throwing people into unmarked
vans and claiming that they're going to expand
to more cities even as soon as this week.
And we'll see if that happens.
We're seeing the authoritarianism and really
the desperation and the disregard for human
life manifest in the demand from Trump that
schools just open in the fall.
Health considerations be damned.
Just get open.
We're seeing Donald Trump's desperation to
prevent people from voting against him manifest
in his unhinged opposition to vote by mail,
which in practice this year just means expand
absentee ballots through the process.
We already have to whoever wants it, just
virulent opposition to that on completely
false and bogus grounds.
And as David Shipler says in this article,
which we're going to link to and I encourage
you to read, and I like this term, Trump has
no moral breaks.
There's nothing there where morality would
pump the brakes for him.
David Shipler goes on to say his values are
those of a mafia boss who rewards and punishes
those who protect or oppose him, who who protect
for opposing him, punishes those who protect
or oppose him.
Now, to be thorough, David Shipler also mentions
our fear could be wrong.
Maybe Trump won't go completely off the rails,
for example.
Maybe Trump won't send these armed paramilitaries
that are now being floated in places like
Portland.
Maybe Trump won't send them to monitor polling
places to intimidate voters in November.
We're worried that he's going to do that,
but maybe he won't do it.
Maybe our fear is overblown and we hope that
it's overblown in the sense that Trump could
be too incompetent or unable to think far
enough ahead to actually do the horrible things
that he would have no moral problem doing.
If Trump stops short of what we fear he would
do.
It would be not because of a moral awakening,
but because he forgets or is incompetent or
is unable or unable to get something done.
But there is this constant feedback loop of
vicious cycle.
Trump's ignorance and delusions of grandeur
and narcissism reinforce his most dangerous
impulses, which when he does and sees that
he gets a reaction, reinforces his narcissism
and delusions of grandeur and viks it victimhood
mentality that no one's been treated as poorly
as him.
You combine this with this silver spoon upbringing
and what appears to be probably some personality
disorders based on the mental health professionals
we've spoken to.
There is no check on Trump's behavior anywhere.
And in fact, when we hear that Trump had an
idea and didn't carry it out, it typically
is because either, A, he gets distracted by
something else or B, a group of people in
his in his administration are able to talk
him out of it or prevent him from doing it.
And then he moves on to something else.
It comes down to what can he get away with?
What can the people around him stop him from
doing?
And it also shouldn't be ignored that the
administration is in itself a threat by virtue
of its mere existence.
This is an administration that has been a
threat to the economy.
It's been a threat to international relations
and our alliances with other countries.
The administration, obviously, in what we're
seeing with coronavirus, has been an existential
threat to public health.
There continues to be a shockingly large percentage
of Americans, though, that still support the
president and still support this administration,
despite everything that's going on right now.
And that is sort of part two of how a desperate
Trump becomes a dangerous Trump.
Some portion of Trump supporters, and I don't
know what.
The number is, but I fear that it's a larger
percentage than we want to admit.
Some portion of Trump supporters are willing
to do violence like real world violence, if
that's what Donald Trump suggests or implies
or in any way signals may be appropriate.
And so when Donald Trump said to Chris Wallace
on Sunday when asked, can you just say you'll
accept the election results, Trump didn't
do it.
He said, I have to see the election results
before I can tell you whether I would accept
them.
When you start to hear about the paramilitaries
showing up in Portland, we have to remember
that a portion of this man's followers are
more than willing.
Some are eager to get out there and commit
physical violence on the streets in the name
of Donald Trump.
Trump has shown us that if we try to predict
how far he will go, we're always wrong.
He's always willing to go further than whatever
our predictions are at any point in time.
And the more cornered he gets and that's what
I believe he increasingly is right now, the
more outrageous and belligerent his behavior
is going to get.
I wonder what stories there are to be told,
which maybe we will hear someday about the
things Trump almost did during this administration
and someone was just barely able to but was
able to stop him from doing it.
You know, the stories about the things he
did are bad enough.
There must be just a treasure trove of nightmares
about the things he almost did that someone
stopped him from doing.
And the next three plus months, three, three
months and a few weeks up until the election
are likely to be the most dangerous Trump
because of the desperation and the feeling
cornered.
And the cognitive stuff is increasingly taking
center stage.
And I want to talk about that a little bit
next.